las acusaciones mutuas tras el ataque a
la cárcel o lenny fica en donde se
mantienen el presidente de ucrania
volodymyr selenski culpó a moscú de los
bombardeos es un llamado para que rusia
sea declarado estado patrocinador del
terrorismo
fue un crimen de guerra ruso deliberado
y agregaría por mi parte que debería
haber el claro reconocimiento legal de
rusia como patrocinador estatal del
terrorismo me dirijo especialmente a
eeuu de américa se necesita una decisión
se necesita ahora
el viernes al menos 50 prisioneros de
guerra ucranianos perdieron la vida los
servicios de inteligencia de ucrania
responsabilizan del ataque a mercenarios
del grupo wagner los familiares de las
víctimas reunidas en la capital
ucraniana también señalaron a rusia de
ser responsable de las muertes en los
jets
como es posible
los rusos mataron a nuestros hijos
mataron a todos son niños no son
culpables de nada solo estaban
defendiendo su país se les ordenó que se
rindieran
los rusos dicen que el ataque fue
realizado con cohetes y mars de
fabricación estadounidense entregados a
ucrania pero el portavoz del ministerio
de defensa ruso no se quedó atrás tras
las acusaciones y arremetió contra kiev
y washington
las listas de nombres de los muertos y
heridos como resultado del ataque con
misiles del régimen de kiev contra los
prisioneros de guerra ucranianos fueron
publicadas en los recursos de
información oficiales del ministerio de
defensa de rusia toda la responsabilidad
política criminal y moral por la
sangrienta masacre contra los ucranianos
recae en selenski personalmente en su
régimen criminal y en washington que los
está apoyando
en todo desde que siguen argumentando
que con el ataque rusia buscaba ocultar
torturas y ejecuciones extrajudiciales
perpetradas en el inifta